[Music]
you are basically a triple threat Doug
Cameron in The Descendants movies you
prove to the world that you can act sing
and dance you are so good at playing mal
and we can listen to your songs all day
every day and you let's be real those
dance moves were epic but we know that
you have some other talents I didn't
make it into the movies and we won't lie
they're a little bit out there no one
can deny the stars of descendants
through you're talented but they all
have some extra secret talents you may
not know about keep watching to find out
which bizarre talents Doug Cameron has
but doesn't often share Sophia Carson if
the cast of descendants were really in
high school together
Sophia might win the most talented
superlative we know that she's a skilled
actor singer and dancer but she also has
a degree in communications what that
means she has some stellar writing
skills she also minored in French Sofia
also had mad fashioned skills just like
her character Evie she was even a guest
judge on Project Runway
Sofia is also a great voice actor she
narrated the audiobook version of The
Descendants book series she also has a
talent for songwriting Sophia can really
do it all
china anne mcclain we are totally
obsessed with China and McClain she did
such a great job with uma storyline in
descendants three China has such an
amazing voice and she has also dabbled
in songwriting it makes total sense
because both of her parents are
songwriters China loves to read and is a
really good student she is good at
drawing she likes to make her own
elaborate greeting cards for friends and
family she is also a master at the hula
hoop that's not an easy skill Thomas
Doherty we know that Thomas Doherty is a
great at playing a pirate but what else
is this Scottish actor good at Thomas is
number one talent is dancing he is
highly trained in lots of dancing types
including hip-hop ballet and jazz he
learned all of that at the mga Academy
of Performing Arts in Scotland Thomas
says he will even talk
dance on the subway or at the bus stop
Thomas also used to play soccer when he
was a kid
Dylan Playfair Gil Gaston may not be the
smartest kid on the Isle of the Lost but
the actor who plays him is totally
different
Dylan play fair is super talented he is
great at various sports he played hockey
before he started acting he also enjoys
wakeboarding and deep-sea diving he
loves all sides of filmmaking he even
produced a political documentary back in
2015
Dylan also learned how to play the
harmonica because he loves country music
so much Sarah Jeffery Sarah Jeffery
showed us that she is a total diva and
descendants 3 we have been listening to
the queen of mean on repeat ever since
we knew since the first movie that Sarah
was a great actress but the third film
proved that she is also an incredible
singer Sarah's other talents are found
in her activism she is passionate about
animals and worked on a campaign called
angels for animals
she is vocal about being biracial and
promoting diversity in Hollywood booboo
Stewart J has a lot of talents and new
sentence but booboo Stewart has even
more booboo is a skilled martial artist
he was even inducted into the martial
arts Junior Hall of Fame he is also into
rock climbing booboo is a very talented
visual artist to his Instagram shows off
a lot of his drawings he even does some
photography and he is so great at it
that means he can act sing and do other
types of arts keep watching to find out
all of Deb Cameron's secret talents
Mitchell Howe the descendents franchise
was Mitchell hopes big break he's a
rising star and so far he has kept a lot
of his personal life under wraps but if
you take a look around his Instagram you
can see some of his hidden talents in
addition to being an amazing singer
Mitchell can play guitar he also really
loves baseball and believe it or not he
has also dabbled in stand-up comedy Anna
Cathcart Anna Cathcart is only 16 years
old but she's already a super successful
actress she has been in lots of huge
hits like to all the boys I've loved
before Anna's Instagram reveals some
pretty great hidden talents she is
amazing at snapping awesome candid
photos with her Polaroid camera she's
also hilarious she is a pro at funny
puns most of her Instagram captions make
us laugh out loud
being naturally funny is definitely a
talent Zackary Gibson much like Mitchell
Howe Zackary Gibson got his first big
break when he was cast in descendants
he plays Doug the smart son of dopey and
true love of Evie Zachary hasn't done a
ton of acting yet but we know we'll see
more great things from him in the future
in his free time
Zachary has several awesome hobbies he
enjoys sports his favorites are road
hockey and basketball he also really
enjoys cooking we love that his hobbies
are so diverse stuff Cameron the star of
descendants is one talented young woman
Duff is amazing at dancing acting and
singing she's currently pursuing her
music career she has several other
talents too she speaks French fluently
she is talented at hair and makeup stuff
also has one really weird skill she can
cross her eyes and make her eyeballs
move individually it's freaky and
adorable
what are your secret talents let us know
in the comments thanks for watching
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to the things for more great
content we'll see you next time
[Music]